the priorities of the Luxembourg
presidency the very first subject I
mentioned was the issue of taxation
we've been able to agree at high
working-level party with all the
colleagues a roadmap for the Luxembourg
presidency in the next six months in the
context of boosting growth the whole
subject of financial services and of
capital markets union is at most
importance we have adopted today at the
2015 recommendations country specific
recommendations European budget of 2016
Cora pair has agreed unanimously on a
council proposal for the budget which is
good news because this page the way for
the discussion with European Parliament
the second subject I would like to
mention is the deepening of EMU before
discussing the deepening of the EMU it
is important to implement what has
already been agreed and discussed at EU
level so an appeal was launched that BR
rd should be implemented by all member
states it was also underlined that the
implementation of the fiscal compact
should be monitored by the Commission
and it will be done all this would
strengthen the credibility of the
functioning of the eurozone and build up
confidence thanks to the existing tools
of banking Union and the ESM we were
able to handle the Greek crisis i would
say in an efficient way because some
instruments were available which were
not available five years ago a recent
experience has shown as very clearly
that respect for commonly commonly
agreed economic and fiscal rules from
all members
is of paramount importance so we welcome
the yesterday's euro summit agreement on
how to move forward with a third Greek
program and now we are concentrating on
finding out possible bridge financing